au 19e siècle au Japon la coutume
voulait que passer 70 ans les personnes
aillent mourir seules dans la montagne
pour ne pas devenir un fardeau pour la
communauté alors peut-être certains
d'entre vous ontil visionné le film à ce
sujet la balade de Narayama qui a
remporté la Palme d'Or au Festival de
canne en
1983 et aujourd'hui cette coutume
n'existe plus et le Japon est devenu le
pays le plus vieux du monde et plus
globalement la population mondiale
vieilli euh et l'Europe vieilli excep le
Japon les 15 pays les plus vieux du
monde sont aujourd'hui européens et la
part des plus de 80 ans va doubler d'ici
2050 donc la population sont viilis et
la part de la population active euh
décroit par rapport à la part de la
population des plus âgé donc il y aura
de moins en moins d'actif pour s'occuper
des plus âgés d'entre nous et puis euh
comme vous et moi les personnes ont bien
l'intention de vieillir dans de bonnes
conditions dans leur domicile jusqu'à
leur mort donc face à ces enjeux
sociétaux il est important de pouvoir
proposer des nouveaux types de services
qui permettent d'accompagner l'avancée
en âge et puis de prévenir les pertes
d'autonomie alors la population vieillit
et puis dans le même temps le numérique
envahit nos vies nous connaissons la
révolution Internet nos vies ont été
bouleversées par les communauté
l'interactivité l'accès au savoir euh au
partage de l'information arrive
maintenant dans nos vies l'Internet des
Objets nos maisons commencent à être
envahies par des objets qui communiquent
aujourd'hui vous avez je pense tous dans
votre poche votre Smartphone vous
pourriez aussi avoir un dispositif qui
vous prévienne quand votre plan de verte
a besoin d'être arrosé voilà et toutes
nos activités génèent des grandes masses
de données et l'analyse de ces grandes
masses de données bah ça s'appelle le
Big Data et c'est la suite c'est quelque
chose qui va nous permettre de
bénéficier encore plus de tout ce que
peuvent nous apporter
euh ces informations ces datas et vous
le voyez déjà un petit peu dans votre
parcours d'internaute quand vous
naviguez et qu'on prend en compte pour
personnaliser ce parcours tout votre
historique de navigation par exemple et
puis après après le Big Data nous allons
pouvoir bénéficier également de ce qu'on
appelle l'Open Data donc là on va vivre
dans des villes réellement
intelligentes l'eau les énergies les
infrastructures publiques les moyens de
transport l'information les
communications
vont être géré beaucoup plus
efficacement au service des citoyens et
dans le respect de l'environnement donc
clairement le numérique envahit nos vies
mais aujourd'hui forcer de constater que
tout de même il existe une réelle
fracture numérique générationnelle
toutes les populations n'ont pas accès
au même type de service alors
aujourd'hui je parle devant une salle
très jeune nous sommes sur le premier x
organisé par des lycéens et tous les
jours sur votre smartphone sur votre
ordinateur vous faites un N un certain
nombre d'actions qui vous sembleent
naturell vous allez consulter des
informations vous réservez un taxi un
uber un moyen de transport vous
contacter un service clientèle qui n'a
plus qu'une plateforme téléphonique et
qui ne prendra votre réclamation que si
vous remplissez un formulaire en ligne
ce sont des services qui ne sont pas
toujours accessibles à à à certaines
populations âgées et moi tous les jours
quand je les utilise ben je me pose la
question de savoir comment ma grand-mère
fait dans le même cas que moi ma
grand-mère elle habite à plus de 400 km
de chez moi et lorsqu'elle doit venir me
rendre visite et qu'elle veut le faire
en autonomie et en indépendance
c'est-à-dire sans que je vienne le
chercher c'estàdire faire 800 km dans la
journée et bien finalement sa seule
possibilité c'est d'aller chercher dans
son placard son gros annuire des page
jaune papier ça existe encore et de
consulter la liste des taxis longue
distance d'en appeler plusieurs pour
savoir lequel serait disponible le jour
où elle a besoin de se déplacer et puis
si elle arrive à en trouver un voilà
elle perra le prix fort pour ce trajet
là plus de 300 €. et al moi j'ai fait le
test en moins de 30 secondes sur les
sites de covoiturage je trouve un
véhicule un chauffeur pour le trajet qui
me convient et pour un tarif de 27 €.
voilà donc on voit bien les écarts de
services auxquels les gens peuvent
prétendre selon qu'ils ont accès ou pas
à certains moyens et finalement moi je
me dis que face à ça et je pense que
vous vous vous posez le même type de
question que
moi il est sûrement possible d'agir moi
je suis entrepreneur du numérique je
suis membre du Conseil National du
Numérique donc je pense que le numérique
est un outil pour répondre à ça et qu'il
est
essentiel de proposer des services des
outils numériques au service du bien
vieillir chez chez soi et puis qu'il est
aussi important d'adapter les services
numériques pour tous à des services en
des services spécialement développé pour
les plus âgés d'entre nous le numérique
envahit nos vies concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'il apporte au SEOR et qu'est-ce qu'il
va pouvoir apporter demain et bien tout
d'abord il faut qu'il soit au service de
tous c'est-à-dire que les outils les
services que l'on développe ne doivent
pas être juste à destination des plus
âgés mais bien s'adresser aussi aux
familles aux aidanss aux proches aux
entreprises qui travaillent au quotidien
auprès des personnes euh je pense aussi
aux association aux institutions aux
collectivités donc le numérique c'est un
outil pour tous et c'est un outil qui
concerne tout euh tout c'est-à-dire dans
le monde du Bien Vieillir la santé le
confort la sécurité le lien social alors
concrètement euh qu'est-ce qu'on a en ce
moment en développement et et qu'est-ce
qui est disponible en terme de santé
euh le numérique permet aux personnes de
devenir actrices de leur santé euh au
contact des personnels soignants
et permet aussi de bénéficier de service
de prévention la prévention c'est très
important prévenir notamment pour les
personnes âgées les chutes avant qu'ell
ne surviennent euh et alerter également
le le évidemment le jour où se elles se
produisent euh alors les les personnes
diabétiques par exemple euh se voi doter
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
glucomètrre connecté chez elle il y a
des box de y santé qui arrivent dans nos
maisons le glucomè connecté bah ça
permet de suivre son taux sucre en
interaction avec son médecin qui du coup
de façon distante a une vision sur
l'évolution de la maladie vous avez bien
évidemment vous connaissez tous les
balances connectées les balances
connecté voilà pour les personnes
vieillissantes en dénutrition ça peut
être un outil très important de suivi
euh vous avez également tout ce qui est
le suivi d'activité donc par soi-même ou
dans le temps tout tous les bracelets
connectés le fameux quantifi self et
vous pouvez maintenant aussi dorénavant
suivre l'activité de personnes dans des
établissements ou dans des logements en
mettant des capteurs sur les compteurs
d'eau et les compteurs d'électricité ce
qui vous donne une bonne vision en
fonction de l'évolution des
consommations au fil des heures au fil
des jours de l'eau et de l'électricité
de ce qui se passe et et de si la
finalement si la personne a une activité
en stable ou ou en baisse vous avez
également des tablettes des tablettes
avec des jeux des jeux de mémoire des
sérius GAM là vous travaillez tout ce
qui est stimulation
cognitive prévenir les dégénérescences
aussi et puis ça permet de retarder
certains symptômes de maladie
d'Alzheimer voilà et puis euh euh
évidemment donc je parlais de la chute
tout à l'heure il faut savoir qu'après
65 ans une personne sur trois chutera
dans l'année à son domicile euh donc
prévenir euh ça peut être euh et bien
euh euh s'assurer que la personne prend
bien son traitement médicamenteux et
puis alerter ça se fait avec aujourd'hui
des systèmes de capteur élaborés une
personne peut avoir chez elle un
interphone euh un dispositif d'appel un
bouton euh pour appuyer s'il lui arrive
quelque chose des capteurs dans son
logement des capteurs de mouvement de
présence de d'ouverture fermeture de
porte et ainsi une anomalie est détectée
automatiquement et les voisins ou alors
la famille ou un plateau distant sont
sont prévenus et peuvent dépêcher sur
place des secours en terme de sécurité
de confort ben vous imaginez bien
qu'effectivement avoir un détecteur de
fumée connecté dans un logement c'est
important pour des personnes qui ont des
pertes d'audition et qui pourrai se
laisser surprendre dans leur sommeil il
est rassurant que dans ces cas-là en cas
d'incendie un plateau euh de
surveillance pourra intervenir et puis
aujourd'hui on voit de plus en plus
apparaître des petits robots dans un
certain nombre de maisons ou
d'établissements des robots compagnons
alors aujourd'hui ils font quoi ils sont
pas encore très élaborés mais ça va
arriver dans les prochaines années ils
font notamment de l'aide à la marche de
l'aide au déplacement et puis euh le
rappel de l'emploi du temps rappel de
l'heure de prise des médicaments voilà
et puis dernier thème et non des
moindres le lien social tous ces
services on parlait de l'Internet tout à
l'heure interactivité communauté toutes
ces plateformes de télémédecine avec
tous les acteurs qui peuvent consulter
le morceau qui les concerne du dossier
patient mais ça permet de travailler
tout ce qui est la coordination des
acteurs et et le lien social la
révolution numérique est en marche pour
le bienvire chez soi euh mais donc comme
je le disais tout à l'heure avec mes
exemples et et ma grand-mère il reste
encore beaucoup de choses à faire et à
construire pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas
passer des services à la personne un peu
classique au sens aide ménagère du terme
à des services numériques à la personne
âgée à quand des conciergeries pour
réellement combler le fossé numérique
générationnel et proposé aux personnes
les plus âgées de lap population
d'accéder à toutes les possibilités
offertes par Internet et puis àand des
services de mobilité un peu adaptés où
les personnes puissent commander un
véhicule autonome qui viendra se
présenter devant leur porte d'entrée et
les emmener où elle le souhait
immédiatement voilà donc j'ai beaucoup
de rêves dans le domaine je n'ai pas
assez d'une vie pour mener à bien mettre
en œuvre toutes ces idées et ces projets
de service innovant pour le bienvillir
de chacun chez soi puisse cette
intervention générer quelques véité
d'entrepreneuriat dans la Silver
économie ou dans l'Internet des Objets
merci